great pleasure to introduce professor
laura nader who is professor of
anthropology at the university of
california at berkeley where she has
been teaching since 1960 just a few
years ago she celebrated 50 years of
teaching at berkeley now this is of
course significant in many ways
for example she was the first woman to
receive a tenure-track job in
anthropology there and then 33 years
later she was the first professor to
teach anthropology to a certain freshman
from southern california who would later
go on to become an assistant professor
at yale that's me
so here's the reader from anthro 3
um
which i keep in my office
as i'm trying to teach introduction to
anthro here i sometimes turn to anthro3
and that was the spring of 1993 wheeler
auditorium and it keeps me inspired to
this day
but in my mind dr nader's long
commitment to teaching anthropology at
berkeley is most significant because she
reminds berkeley what it means to be
berkeley
not a brand not a logo not a passing
theoretical fad but an attitude
a deeply anthropological attitude of
critique and intellectual daring which
is forged from a willingness to speak
out and to ask straightforward direct
simple
yet always penetrating questions even if
those questions risk ruffling a few
feathers
in an age when academic anthropology has
increasingly been reduced to a career
choice or an over pro or has become over
professionalized dr nader shows what it
means to live an anthropological life
which is at heart a life of questioning
the world we live in
she had a way of thinking that she
introduced to us students at berkeley a
way which i'll never forget in which i
teach my introduction to anthropology
classes today which is the idea that
anthropologists should be interested in
those things which make their antennae
go up and she would always say this in
class that made my antennae go up
that is they should always be ready to
be roused into curiosity by strange
features of social life by inequalities
injustices dogmas ideologies
as an anthropologist when your antennae
go up you start to ask questions you
conduct research you challenge
assumptions
today
as the american public university system
is increasingly under threat dr nader
also brings a sense of history which
enables her to remind us all precisely
what a great public university can look
like
and she refuses to watch the dismantling
of that system without a fight from the
top down she has been demanding
accountability from university budget
offices protesting the corporatization
of the university and asking for leaders
to respond to their faculty
even in the high rolling 1990s when i
was a student there when no one seemed
to notice anything but how many new
cafes were appearing next to the
libraries she was always already
sounding alarms about the selling of the
university to the highest bidder did you
know that the museum of anthropology at
berkeley is really called the robert
loewy museum a fact which is buried
under the avalanche of hearst family
dollars that bought the name
did you know that there was a time when
engineering buildings on public
university campuses were not named after
the same engineering firms that compel
those universities to provide them free
job training
from the bottom up she has also been an
inspiration to generations of berkeley
students reminding them that it's okay
to be passionate about the world about
one's education and that it's not just
okay to rock the boat and challenge
received wisdom but that it's part of
one's civic duty to do so
now she doesn't hand out trophies to
students but she pushes them through
prickly and provocative instigation
in the late 1990s when i was a student
there for example she had the guts to
boldly walk into a classroom and ask
berkeley students why they had all
become lobotomized
we all nodded in approved unison if only
to recognize that by nodding we were
proving her point
we quickly learned that thoughtful minds
should resist the seduction of agreeing
about everything
this is the danger of what she famously
called harmony ideologies where calm
consensus and smooth tranquility come at
the expense of real civic debate
disagreement and agitation for social
justice
we some have called her paranoid
untrusting in response she reminds us
that the opposite of paranoia is even
worse trust annoying
the fact that we don't have a word like
trust in oya says a lot about the
central dogmas in our society the
balance of the bounds of thinkable
thought
and challenging central dogmas and
unraveling assumptions is at the center
of laurenador's anthropological life
which is not just a career but i would
say it's a calling
today i look forward to learning more
about the central dogma that prevent us
from thinking critically about energy
this talk and her visit today have been
made possible by many yale organizations
including the climate and energy
institute the department of anthropology
center for middle eastern studies the
center for latin american and iberian
studies the whitney humanities center
and the frank program in humanities and
sciences i think just that number of
organizations shows how many how many
different intellectual lines of inquiry
her work speaks to but special thanks go
to the graduate students in our program
who organized this visit especially
chris hebden who's been organizing this
visit in the same week that he's
preparing for his quals exams and also
sadie randall who's been helping him as
well so
with no further ado i'd like to have you
please join me in welcoming professor
laura nader and the title of her talk
today is energy and human frailty
this is a critical time for anthropology
terribly needed in this world today
we're a generalist field
like the ecologists
we're not just specialists
but
anthropology remember is greater than
what anthropologists are doing today
there's so much specialization
worldwide
among elites
that
they don't understand
the problems of coordination
and it results with the technology in
what i call the fried brains problem
the inability to connect the dots that's
what you're supposed to learn to do in
antibiotics
connect the dots
these are critical times
because of our technologies
because of what humans have participated
in the developer of what's happening on
the planet
and we desperately need coordination
we cannot just think that technology is
going to save us
and all you need to do is look and see
what happened
in
lax
when the man came in with the shoot him
up
nothing coordinated they've just done a
review of that they had all the
technology to immediately have somebody
on the spot took over 10 minutes
and you could name a number of issues
like that so
think about
what i have to say today with me
and in that context of the need for
scope
sherry washburn the physical
anthropologist in our department
many years ago said he wanted students
to have a specialty
to be able to teach the introductory
course in anthropology across the field
integrated anthropology course and he
wanted us to think about new questions
for the future
think about when you do those three
things
which require specialization
scope what the field is
and
where the field should be heading
now
today i want to deal with
energy science and scientists
and i have a talk that i have written up
partly because i want to get a log in
and how much time do i have here
that would be chris
50 minutes 15 minutes
okay do my best
uh
energy science and scientists
and i've been working on this since the
1970s when very few people were i was
invited by the national academy of
sciences to come and participate in a
conference on breeder reactors it was a
big project
and i told them that they had the wrong
major
and my siblings are both working on
energy i have no clue but the guy on the
other end of the line said are you the
anthropologist and i said yes he said we
need an anthropologist
so i went on board knowing nothing about
energy but
and knowing not a lot about the
scientists i was going to be dealing
with there were 300 people
299 males one anthropologist
a few sociologists historians but
most of more physicists are engineers
so
now since the 1970s
there are a lot of anthropologists now
zeroing in on energy studies
and you look and see what they're doing
and they're one specializes in oil
that's okay coal working on coal working
on nuclear ramps and so on
but i think there are very few i may be
the only one working on the experts
and when i was with these group of 300
299 experts
uh i
at one point
i realized uh
that when there are men in groups or
like primates
they buy with each other
and so i said you know is there any
reason why we can't have any more women
in this
organization this group because it
lasted five to five years
and
i said do you think i enjoy being the
only woman in this group
and they said you seem to be handling it
very well laura
and
it was interesting because they never
added anyone
but when i was invited to an all-male
conference in damascus and i said the
same thing
i would prefer not to come to an
all-male conference they invited 20
women 20 scientists
so there's really it was weird watching
these guys vying with one another
and i was taking notes
and they say are you studying that far
and i said of course
and they laughed
little did they know
so i am one of the few anthropologists
dealing with energy science and
scientists
in the militarization of these people
who are deeply embedded in corporate
now i'm thinking about the specific
science question in human frailty i
decided to go look at some earlier
material i went back to a book that was
given to us when we were graduate
students at harvard and it was a book
winner grand conference on
a man's role in changing the face of the
planet
1955.
it was really it's an amazing book for
those who are interested in these issues
you ought to get a copy of
you know secondhand copy or something
this is before the concept of
anthropocene was popularized by nobel
laureates and so on
recognizing that humans were the key
drivers of the earth system
and it was a challenge
to those who claim that energy solutions
are purely technological
anybody who tells you that the solution
to our energy problems are technological
they don't know what they're talking
about
whether they're social scientists or
physics physics physicists or engineers
that say that
and i'll tell you why
in 55
there was an ecologist in this
conference and he put it this way toward
the end i have become increasingly
doubtful about the science utility as a
tool for solving all human problems
i have been distressed at finding some
of us here talking as though we regarded
science as sort of a white magic and
answer to all problems a direct road to
truth objective factual circle but the
scientist can never attain any absolute
objectivity since he must also deal with
the mind of the observer
the sciences and the humanities form a
false dichotomy because science is one
of the humanities
he ends by clarifying that man requires
science and technology for survival but
for science to survive it needs to be
humanized
he says perhaps our western world so
proud of its technical advantages is
starting a sort of process of suicide
through its failure to assimilate
science into its general culture
or as a curious consequence of the
scientist's own self-important attitude
those are really strong words
all right then i went to
a publication
by nuclear physicist jose goldenberg
from
brazil admit him in hawaii
and he put out a book called
world energy assessment
energy and the challenge of
sustainability
this was initiated by four scientists
from four continents brazil sweden india
and the united states
and at the beginning their approach was
so much at odds with their colleagues
that they thought they were called as
maverick visionaries
their position was noted in the
following this is what they said
and tell me if this doesn't sound like
anthropology
the achievement of sustainable
development
dictates a global perspective a very
long time horizon
and immediate policy measures that take
into account the long lead time needed
to change the system
the implications for the way science is
practice is made clear it cannot be
business as usual
then i went to
another book
by edited by mcnish and logan it's
called flammable societies
studies on the socioeconomics of oil and
gas
and when they concluded the editors
quoted from pierre brudu
the following
neoliberalism
is a political program
disguised as science to increase the
economic power of the few
think about that
goldenberg at all were calling for a
long time horizon
to include what happened after the
discovery of agriculture and after the
rise of western industrialism
anthropology
that's what it was
now the final read
came in the form of
reading my alumni journal from harvard
and they were the review of a new book
by a woman named elaine scary how many
of you know her have heard of the blame
scary
she's written a book called thorough
nuclear monarchy
choosing between democracy and doom
she's a professor of aesthetics and
value at harvard and she has pointed
nuclear weapons undo anything that could
be meant by democracy
we had a choice get rid of nuclear
weapons or get rid of congress and the
citizens we got rid of congress and the
citizens
she's pointing to the concentration of
outside
outsized violent forest in the hands of
the american president
that has largely undermined
our three part form of government
that the framers of the constitution had
created
one man
elected by a minority
of the world's people and a minority
of america says so many americans don't
even vote
can destroy the earth
wherever he or she goes the suitcase
goes with him
and that's
the nuclear
bomb
how many of you ever seen the day after
trinity
one person
that's all nobody else has seen it
you want to understand something about
how science operates and human fred to
go look at
it was made by humanities foundation
grant
in california
and uh
it basically talks about how the bomb
was made
and how
the scientists themselves could not stop
the making of the bomb even though they
had qualms
they were in a flow
and they couldn't stop
they had to see if the gadget worked if
they called them
they knew that it was going to be used
on japan
they had left two cities unbombed so
there could be a good experiment
afterwards they in this film they
interviewed some of the people that were
involved one of whom was oppenheimer's
brother and they said
what were you thinking he said when the
bomb went off he said
first
i was glad it worked
then i thought
oh my god
there are people
human friend
now science
is one of those contemporary
activities we take for granted as
natural something that's always going to
be there
um
medieval historian of science lynn white
reminds us that
it's not necessarily a permanent thing
science as we know
that the romans were creative and
originally but there was no ancient
roman science even though they knew
about greek science
in the case of islamic science roughly
covering 750 to 1150 a.d
islam was a leader in scientific
activity but by the 11th century the
whole focus of islamic culture shifted
and science was deliberately abandoned
in relation to christianity
science had also had a varied history
there was a time when only spiritual
values had significance and lynn white
also called for an increasing awareness
on the part of sciences of the relation
of science activity to the total human
context because in quotes
our modern habit of regarding scientific
progress as inevitable may in fact be
dangerous to his continuing vigor
no faith can afford to be re to remain
unexamined
the space especially faith in the
science and technology which is shaping
our lives
we know from other contexts that true
believers can have a pernicious effect
on the quality of freedom and the
tolerance for diversity
in relation to science and technology
there are believers
among those who do science and
technology and those who consume this
work in the form of ideas and material
goods etc
the processes of control that have
triggered a critical response both
inside and outside the community
are related to different clusters of
beliefs and there is building steam in
universities throughout the western
world dealing with the issue of science
as ideology
and science and technology
as
anti-democratic which is what elaine
scary's point is
some speculate that these concerns
arise because of the problems inherent
in science
but not because of the problems inherent
but because of a particular kind of
science that has evolved in context of
the militarization of american society
nsf was militarily oriented that's how
it came into being
so what follows here a few comments
about
what influences science the construction
of the science
and technology energy culture
one that has hubris and very little
humility
and a growing detachment from the broad
human context
a little history
1981 shortly after this national academy
work that i did
i was invited by the mitre corporation
to give a talk
on
um
whatever i wanted
and i called it barriers to think you
knew about energy
it was the most sought after talk they
published it
was republished in physics today
republished in chem tech and more
recently republished in the industrial
physicists
i think very few anthropologists have
probably read it anybody in this room
ever read it it says physics today
that's impressive
barriers to think about
knew about energy was a commentary on
the mindsets that i encountered among
the physicists chemists and engineers
with whom i was working
the piece generated a lively response
from the scientific community and i'll
refer to one that came from a nobel
laureate at harvard
he describes the changing intellectual
climate in western science he says yes
that's the way it is the well-guided and
well-guided by inexpressed system of
rewards and punishment in the first half
of this century we had a generation of
monumental physicists einstein bore
eisenberg paulie schrodinger all of them
knew that what physics is about is
reality
and that physics science can explore
only part of reality and by far the
smaller part
that kind of thought he ended is now
virtually forbidden in the scientific
literature
how can thought be forbidden in the
scientific literature
a second letter begins to answer that
question
this guy is at the
berkeley livermore the berkeley
national lab he says i noticed over the
years
irrationality on the part of many
colleagues when it comes to discussing
matters relating to energy
all the data in the world cannot bring
about change in energy strategies once
the person is decided on a particular
course
this is all the more strange as many
people these people are competent
intelligent scientists who usually alter
their views in the light of new data
like fukushima for example
i've heard about energy policy
but the disagreements are really
disagreements over values and scientists
don't know how to deal with values
they feel uncomfortable
the inability to recognize the source of
the conflict leads to the nonsensical
and ridiculous statements you mentioned
in your account
now if you summarize the mindsets
that i encountered in looking at these
people
i would say the following
people who thought different they were
told they were off the track
they kept saying you're off the track
bar
and i'd say if we knew where the track
was we wouldn't be here
was a lack of respect for diverse
solutions
there was a lack of respect for
different kinds of intelligence there
was an avoidance of discussing
technologies other than nuclear or coal
abstract rather than concrete thinking
led to the problem
if you figure out how to dispose of
nuclear waste or you think you can
ensure safety that's as good as doing it
it's really amazing if they've got it on
paper
they can do it then they know they can
do it never mind that they don't do it
memos
discussed nuclear coal and non-nuclear
non-nuclear was solar
and upon different occasions was
described as an orphan child not very
intellectually challenging just a bunch
of mirrors
my notebook was full of observations
such as
in their lexicon change means
maintaining the status quo
progress is equal to growth
gnp is equal to increased human welfare
energy growth means more economic growth
more energy expenditure does not change
lifestyle well less does society's only
change from the top down technological
fixes can solve human problems and
forestall crisis
in addition to these beliefs
which although unsubstantiated by
evidence
we're powerful driving forces i ask
specific questions such as how could you
go ahead with nuclear without having
solved a nuclear waste problem
and i heard because it's fun
it's interesting it's fascinating
even though the same people would
unself-consciously agree that such a
direction might be dangerous
i tried to understand the mindset that
could say
yes the big the whole the boat has a big
hole in it but we'll take care of it
later
this was all after thomas kuhn had
written his blockbuster
on the structure of scientific
revolution
consequence thinking is essence
don't expect the scientists to be
leaders
no skin in the game
you know what that means no skin in the
game they can do they have done whatever
they want to do they're not responsible
who's responsible
for nuclear warheads
wasn't passed by congress wasn't okay by
the citizen
and the people in the military who
pushed it they're not responsible
i began to notice
that they talked about human beings in a
strange way
they'd say well we have a nuclear
accident we lose two percent of the
population only two percent
and i would say i refuse to be in a room
with people who talk about human beings
in terms of percentages
how many people are two percent
it would be very uncomfortable
what they were doing is distancing
themselves from the consequence
of their work
distance
so for all the bravo about quantitative
work
you have to understand
that it also has this function of
distance
so
the assumptions that were made
about happiness
and quality of life and so forth and
increased energy were just not
evidentially based
between 1935 and 55 you had more energy
and you had better quotes quality of
life measured but between 55 and 75 you
didn't so there's no necessary
correlation to be found there although
they always say the quality of life we
need all this energy
so it was really bad science that i was
part partly witnessing
now the book that we put out the
national academy was called energy
choices in a democratic society
we were concerned
with what kinds of energy technologies
are compatible with a democracy
and that question is bothersome to
people
because what do you mean i mean we need
the energy the industrial process itself
no we're a democracy there's certain
technologies that don't go well with
democracy like what nuclear
why nuclear has to be
monitored it's dangerous it's not voted
on
the waste problem you just list all the
problems
a tendency
between conflicts between efficiency and
democratic ideology
between
defining complex problems as technical
and resolvable by expertise the idea of
citizen participation
all these we chose to disaggregate in
our study energy choices of democratic
society we described two future
scenarios one in which you had high
efficiency and the other low use and
high technology
so we said you can have
more
more efficiency
and lots of technology if you like it
but you don't need to have more energy
use
the high energy productivity scenario
was designed to explore the use of
energy in a society looks very much like
our own
uh but projected into the future without
major changing in attitudes or we
explored a society in which attitudes
towards resources changed a society
that's decentralized and people with
people who value thrift and self-reliant
a nation that's not vulnerable to
terrorism and violence and so on we're
decoupling
illustrating the possibilities it's not
inevitable the inevitability syndrome is
very powerful
it has to go in that direction you can't
stop it it's now going we have to see if
the if the
the
gadget will work
the inevitability center drives a lot of
this stuff and that's why the experts
need the generalists to say wait a
minute i can give you 10 examples of
where it's not necessarily so
okay what was the reaction
to
energy choices
in a democratic society
it was denial
we were against progress
we were describing impossible futures
we were planning future worlds that go
against the grain of human nature now
these are scientists saying what do they
know about human nature
right
what do they know about any of the
things they're talking about
much of what we thought was possible for
the year 2010 happened before the report
was published
and actually they didn't want to publish
even the final report
because they kept sending it back this
was a sixth revision you really have to
you have to just decide when you're in a
situation like that i'm going to stay
with it to the end to see how this story
ends
and the sixth revision he said well well
first i said you know we need less less
pros more
more clock more chart more what they say
more charts quantitative
i said after you talk about love how can
we talk about happiness how do you talk
about all these things we value in
numbers
and then they'd write back and say
more
charts less pros these guys don't read
so we have an illiteracy problem
among our smartest experts
these guys don't breathe
another reaction
quads about the same reaction was to
impugn our methodology we weren't
qualitative
enough they wanted more tables and so
forth and john holdren calls this the
illusory precision
illusory precision
a sense of concrete reality where there
is nothing
and much that's important is left out
like the things i talked about civil
rights freedom democracy quality of life
and so forth
the problem of mindset
is discussed a lot today
in connection with concern over
creativity in american science and
technology if you live in california all
you hear about innovation creative
americans have to learn creative
information
when you see people talking that much
about creativity and innovation you know
that there's a lack of it
just look at silicon valley
a bunch of techno twits
who are making lots of money
doing dumb things like
google glasses
bragging about you know self-driving
cars
never mentioning mass transportation
problems in our country
spending lots of money and getting
patted on the back for doing it
and bragging they brag about
google glasses
when i watched i went to a place where
they were showing off the google glass
and i looked at the guy and i said what
does it do he said oh he said
let me tell you what do you want to know
i said i went to my first computer
conference in 1963
in lake arrowhead
california can you find it because chris
had already found it for me it's all
online that was my first conference on
computers and that's where i decided not
to do it
we predicted snowden etc
and he said okay
if i had more time i could find it
i know you can't tell me what does it do
to the
eyes oh he said the eyes get used to but
now what does it do with the biology of
the eye
i never thought
google glasses
try driving with google glasses to worse
themselves
which they're beginning to do
so a whole business of
of uh
what we these mindsets
the need for
uh is something that
that is pulling
science and engineers
one way or the other because they are
loyalties to the organization that pays
their salaries
now this is important
a few of these people speak up but
others remain silent even on questions
of science finding because if you do
open your mouth dissent is punished
at one level there is awareness of
censorship
both american and european physicists
who corresponded with me
identified with the group think problem
or what one person described as the mind
cage and many made specific reference to
censorship in our national laboratories
to say that dissenting scientists are
harshly punished brings to mind the
cases of soviet scientists who protested
the totalitarian regime
american scientists have often supported
the cause of scientists who are punished
for dissent in other countries
yet when an american scientist is
punished for dissent
there is not comparable protest
these scientists work who work in
organizations that punish descent are
never heard about
i have a sibling who worked at oak ridge
and i had my husband worked at lawrence
berkeley so we know i know a little bit
about how this dissent question works
but the exception an interesting case of
public uh revelation is goffman tampa
any of you ever hear of goffman tampa
they were two physicists who in the fall
of 1969
revealed their findings on low-level
radiation and they asked the atomic
energy commission to increase the margin
of safety by lowering the permissible
radiation
dose
the country was beginning to move ahead
with construction of nuclear power
plants had mostly heard about the
friendly atom and energy to chief
demeter it was therefore strange to hear
a report on radiation risks
pure
propaganda
gotham and tampon had extrapolated from
the hiroshima nagasaki data and there
were american physical anthropologists
who worked on that issue as well
in order to estimate the effects of the
radiation emissions following the
federal radiation standards of the
cancer and leukemia cases that would be
caused they expected their data to be
examined and may be refuted but a public
debate was launched and they were
fighting for their jobs
the scientists working with them were
reassigned
the budgets were reduced
travel allowances were cut
and with each act a degradation
accompanied personal attacks on their
integrity professional integrity what
was most instructive about this story
however was not a single scientist
either at the livermore lab or any other
national lab stood up to defend them
they would have done it for the soviet
side they didn't do it for the american
scientists
i think it needs to be pointed out that
the scientists workplace in national
labs is different from university
departments they have no tenure
protection
and until recently no due process i
worked with a group of scientists and
lawyers and so forth faculty of the
university for eight of us for about
eight years trying to get scientific
freedom
for the scientists that work at the lab
written into the contract
because
without time for freedom they can
discover all they want and they can't
say
and you can't say it to the public
that's why the whole question of science
and the democratic society becomes
important
it was james bryant conant 1951
president of harvard
who said that decay in science sets in
with repression
and he plea pleaded for the importance
of absolutely untrammeled discussion and
debate which was not being heated by
large-scale ads the intimidation
sometimes is so powerful that to argue
that labs ought to be democratized or
that scientists
ought to be able to dissent
is received with hostility even today
and when we weren't able to do what we
wanted to do to give academic freedom to
the scientists in the labs
we then
pursued the argument that
the university of california should
detach from the labs
because if they can't have scientific
freedom and they're going to be run by
corporations then we don't want that we
don't want them using the reputation of
the university to make it seem like they
did have freedom
now these national labs were started by
military
forces during world war ii before
enduring
and job security is only one
of the pressures there are other
controls that stem from the belief that
only a specialist in the subject should
ask questions
scientists can
on top can tell those below what to do
just like in the military
a theoretical physicist told me he
didn't ask questions about nuclear
energy because it was not his field
so she gets narrower and narrower it's
not only you have to be a scientist you
have to be a citizen you have to be a
nuclear scientist to you know check
so then objectivity becomes shared
subjectivity
and group think reactions lead one to
question what experts are practicing
science and when they are practicing
magic organization
now
some time
ago i attended this meeting of breeder
reactor scientists and i went with the
linguist nikki foster
i didn't trust myself by that time
and one scientists observed in our
presence that what anthropologists do is
philosophy not science
philosophy another volunteer is when you
can't quantify and when results are
based on opinion
as if their results aren't based on
opinion too cheap to meet her are you
kidding
they proceeded with the following
exchange
jack says to bill phil i like your
numbers they agree with mine
bill beams and says how about jim has
jim generated any numbers yet jack says
no why don't you send your numbers over
before he gets ego involved with
generating his own
objective quantifying
again what scientists say when they're
guaranteed anonymity straightforward
a chairman of the physics department
said the following the price of
questioning or dissent can result in
professional ostracism
the nuclear scientists observed those of
us who would seriously question the
scientific goals of our peers face an
ultimate blacklist from our profession
by the entrenched establishment
unbeknownst to the general public the
leading physical scientists are not
einstein-like characters but more likely
intelligent bureaucrats intent on
building or maintaining their empires
so if we were going to examine science
with the objectivity and detachment that
we need
then we would have to conclude that only
part of what scientists do is scientific
which is why in my naked science book i
ask the question when is science
scientific
when do they follow their own their own
rules
demystifying science
is often done by great scientists
so
if you've ever heard of
aaron schroeder
an austrian theoretical physicist
he asked how true is it
that science furnishes us with a body of
truth which is objective and stable
unmolded by human temperament human
temperament
and in answering the question
schrodinger puts the exact sciences in
quote he says a selection has been made
in choosing the raw material on which
the present structure of science is
built
that selection must have been influenced
by circumstances other than scientific
thus far physical science cannot claim
to be independent of its environment
and so if we go back through an
indefinite series of stages in
scientific advance we finally come to
the first conscious attempt of primitive
man to understand and form a logical
mental picture of events observed in the
world about it
and then he talks about primitive man
who formed for himself
his scientific constructive mental from
the surrounding necessity of bodily
substances
now who could he have been influenced by
in anthropology
schrodinger
who has written about this in his public
anybody
who wrote about magic science and
religion
you know malanowski wrote a book called
magic science and religion
maybe the greeks too but that
was influenced
so what male mask did was
he uh he wrote it in a very
public manner public anthropology manner
because he wanted this to be he did it
sort of implicitly
and later on the beach said he just sort
of said this applies to american labs as
long as it applies to you know the
amount of
programmers
he said
the trailbranders
fish easily in the inner lagoons where
abundant fish can be found without
danger and uncertainty in contrast with
the open
and dangerous seas where the yield
varied he said in the lagoon fishing
where man can rely upon this knowledge
and skill
magic does not exist
while in the open sea fishing full of
danger and uncertainty there is
extensive magical ritual to ensure
secure safety and good results
well when they develop nuclear they had
no idea they had no experience they
couldn't predict it was partly magic
it was wishful thinking
too cheap to meet her right and all the
other things that they
sold to us and we bought
and even after fukushima
obama
okay the development of new nuclear
plants in the united states although we
haven't had any new ones since the 70s
how do you explain that that is so
bizarre you need some imaginative
anthropologist to put an explanation on
it
how could you go after fukushima how
could the japanese vote in a prone
nuclear
leadership after fukushima
but the prime minister
who was lied to by temple
he now flipped
he never again if he
pursued
nuclear he's
he's sanity
so then you have to begin to explain
this and of course some people explain
it because the japanese want to have
readers because they never forgot not
attacking your hiroshima
if you think that's just in their past
just think again
they want to have the wherewithal
to make the nuclear weapon if they have
to
and i read in the new york times sunday
new york times the u.s is now bringing
back some of the materials
uh so they can't
but
that's the whole issue with with iran
pointing the fingers in iran that have
allah and there in the middle east
you've got israel with nuclear weapons
there's nothing rational about these
decisions that are being made
and they're they're interwoven with
human frailty
now um
in the true banders
the whole society shared the
understanding of risk and uncertainty
and one of the dangers in modern science
is that magic and religion in science
are not distinguished by the main actors
as they are among the trobrianders
scientific practices ideology
as the nobel laureate lamented the
scientists of today are not of the
generation of the einsteins the
schrodingers of that day and the physics
teacher put it this way he said having
come from a family of physicists having
known many of the men whose names were
legend in their times
i sometimes suggest that most of the
practitioners whose attitudes and
blindnesses you properly decry simply
are not physicists at all they're
technicians
a livermore scientist made the same
point
when he confessed nuclear is a fact of
life and my job is working to find ways
to live with it workers do what they're
told scientists at los alamos labs
complain
when the s was removed from their badges
and they're no longer set apart from
other workers
but there are other things they do not
even notice that they might complain
about because it's part of the control
part of the system of denial denial is
very important to study today
the jargon used at defense labs at the
department of defense itself
include such terms as for those of you
who are linguistically inclined
energetic disassemblies
you know what that is
that's a nuclear explosion
alternative hostility
that's a nuclear war enmity stimulation
that's propaganda
service killed in action
permanent pre-hostility is peace
and circadian deregulation is death
it was the most bizarre experience
perhaps the most ubiquitous inequity in
democratic society
has been the inability of those who will
be affected by energy technologies to
penetrate the secrecy the jargon the
numerology in order to inform themselves
of what's going on and to organize
politically around the inequities that
deal with life
we're caught in mind cages
that inhibit planning for survival
distinguishing between waging war
committing suicide or genesis
unable to imagine waging peace and
unable to develop peace technology not a
single u.s defense research lab that's
waging peace
although they tried it los alamos
i have a few more minutes
scientific policy makers
discuss the future in ways that reflect
their inability to look at the present
laboratory personnel project into the
future the reality they cannot face in
the present and then they argue over
future projections this is what were
real
in 1985 there was a meeting a symposium
on nuclear winter held at the american
astrology meetings
and after that i went there was invited
to speak at los alamos
but there were physical scientists at
that meeting who spoke about nuclear
winter
about communities and families as if
things would return to normal after a
nuclear war
it was bizarre
i mean i can't community there's nothing
i learned in bugabooga that could
compete with me
an advertisement for the book nuclear
winter claimed that this book was an
authoritative account of the
consequences of nuclear war for humans
and the environment the first
comprehensive description of the world
after nuclear war that includes both
effects on humans and the phenomena of
nuclear women
it's pseudoscience to ask how people
would cultivate their women
and people were writing about the fact
that after
the nuclear winter it'll be easier to
park
because there'll be fewer people
it's useful to
examine the beliefs the myths myths
about science
as a way to decolonize our thinking
about science that the scientists
themselves want us to do
i got a hundred letters from these these
people
and phone calls
so they need help for all the reasons
that i've stated they can't dissent
and
the scientific knowledge
we've just seen this film losing
knowledge that has been destroyed in the
name of progress
we don't think about that the botanical
science of the american amazonian
indians the agricultural know-how the
mayan indians the drug know-how of
people throughout the globe
people lived in different
mountains desert zones and they survived
because they solved their problem with
ingenuity
they domesticated animals they bred
new plants they built seaworthy vessels
and their philosophy had to be
ecological
because there were too few knowledge
specials
that's why we did naked science
so to understand what's happening in
western science you have to understand
the relationship in scientific research
between the production of a research
community the production of scientists
the production of knowledge the
production of research equipment
sometime after the development of the
bomb
robert wilson the physicist said our
life was directed to do one thing
it was though we have been programmed to
do that and we are as autonomous
autonomous we're doing it
amazing how technology tools trapped one
we all kept working because the
machinery had caught us in their trap
and we were anxious to get this thing to
go off
human frail
whenever there's need for legitimating
science and technological positions the
concept of progress is utilized
nuclear is still closed in technology is
progress
and the presence rather than the
consequence is the measure
in spite of things like fukushima
the progress model silhouettes the
benefit sides of the technology the
hazard side takes a back seat
enthusiasts claim the work must proceed
without delay hurry hurry because of the
potential benefits for human life
do potential benefits
deserve the big risk
the belief that science always moves
forward
this is another nobel laureate
represents a form of laissez-faire
nonsense dismally reminiscent of the
credo that american business has left to
the self will solve everybody's problems
just as the success of a corporate body
and making money need not set the human
condition ahead neither does every
scientific advance automatically make
our lives
more
meaningful so when people refer
to the crisis in science today
they're referring to the fact that the
faithful are beginning to think
about the scientific endeavor in a more
critical way those of you who take
science magazine and read to read the
editoriums
it's
like 90 percent propaganda
we have to get people in science why see
people with mathematics they have to
know mathematics to do science and they
have no idea what they're doing
they just our
business as usual
if people are not interested in doing
science there may be some reasons for it
some of which i talked about here
paul fire robin
takes
makes the observation that
non-scientific ideologies practices
theories traditions can become powerful
rivals
and can reveal major shortcomings of
science if they're given a fair chance
to compete
and so people look at
critical situations and i said who got
us out of that sometimes it's just plain
joke
because he does the obvious thing
if you think your pain is going to be
hijacked you get up when you do
something about it you don't sit there
but if we all become automotive
then
the problems do you know about or
talk to you about from the freshman
period
result
paul fire oven
was controversial
because he takes the position that the
superiority of western science is not
the result of comparisons of achievement
but the result of political
institutional and military force
i taught a course last year a seminar on
science and power
a small number of people come to take
such a seminar
powerful if you compare
any other science tradition now i know
scientists i know anthropologists who
think there's only one science european
well they might give credit to the
greeks
but it's european
what about chinese science
what about islamic science
were any unmilitarized psychiatrist did
idiom ever develop a technology that
could destroy the planet
you know you can evaluate your sciences
on that basis
so
science is one ideology
among
basically what this
leads me to think is that
it was
lined up
is that
science needs just plain joel and jane
they need to be regulated by the
generalists
who is a generalist left in our society
the people who ask the common sense
questions
that's why we argued for citizen
participation
what's going on around here that was a
favorite question we asked at the
national institutes of mental health
and you couldn't get an answer from the
bureaucrats
nasa funded recently a study
that was headed
as an nsf money industrial civilization
headed for irresistible
irreversible collapse question mark how
many of you saw that
very interesting report
and they're talking about how the system
could be
unraveled
by investigating the human nature
dynamics of past cases of collapse which
the archaeologists have done a beautiful
job on
the project identifies the most salient
interrelated factors which explain
civilizational decline and determine the
risk of collapse today namely population
climate water agriculture and energy
no inclusion of the experts
and the power division
it's not just those people population
climate everything is diagnosis what do
you think the problems of the world that
population knows
yes but
what how does that work
now we say climate change
how does that involve experts in the
elites
these factors i say can lead to collapse
when they converge to generate two
crucial social features the stretching
of resources due to strain placed on the
ecological carrying capacity and the
economic stratification of society into
elites and mass commoners
that is the rich in the poor
occupy was about that
occupy was stimulated greatly by nancy
politici teaching your department
david craven
accumulated surplus is not evenly
distributed throughout society
controlled by an elite the massive
population law produced producing the
west wealth has only allocated a small
portion of it by elites usually just
above the system
this is an amazing report
that could have been written by an
anthropologist
and maybe was i don't know it's written
by a man named ahmed and i don't know if
he's related to akba
the anthropologists who said they
haven't had chair in washington dc
but what this shows is that
human beings are vulnerable
the one thing i keep saying to my
students and my friends the one that
social science finding
that nobody can receive
ever
is that human beings make mistakes
we know that
human beings make mistakes
that's part of the component now some
people argue that it's because we still
have a paleolithic mind
in the paleolithic time someone comes at
you with
an arrow you get out of the way
but if somebody comes at you with
radiation
you have no way of getting out of the
way you don't even see it latency period
is too long maybe 10 or 15 years
how many of you read about the uss
reagan
and the sailors on the uss ring anybody
5500 sailors
went to
help in the tsunami in japan
they were not warned about radiation
they got there and there was a meltdown
they were in the water they were washing
themselves
with brushing their teeth drinking the
water it was radiating
about three months later they begin to
notice things
you know disney blocking out when they
drag
and then
can't walk
leukemia
breast problem
baby problems the whole works
within a month within three year period
there's a suit
against
the japanese company
by 155 american sailors
and the suit is being carried by
two lawyers in san francisco
and what that suit will point out is
you have to have some skin in the game
you can't just experiment with humans
and not be
not be responsible
you have to be held responsible by the
law
and temple has to be held responsible
they didn't sue the navy because the
navy apparently didn't know that there
had been a meltdown but the company knew
there had been enough
so
human frailty on all levels and also
human greed
and these are
important issues for us to consider when
we're talking about energy as a social
and cultural problem
energy is not a technological problem
it's a social and cultural problem i'll
just end on that and hope you have some
questions
we have about 20 25 minutes or so for
questions and i'll let you field your
own questions
it seems like all your examples really
showed that the sort of military
industrial complex is sort of there at
the beginning of a lot of these
institutions too so i'm wondering if you
can given your experience over time
you can reflect
militarization among people who are very
in a corporate setting but i wonder also
if there's been a corporatization or how
those have changed over time among the
communities
thank you for that
this question about the militarization
of science it has come about
incrementally
so people didn't quite notice it like i
didn't know the nsf was started by the
defense department sherry washburn told
me it was for national security
so
it came in slowly
and actually my sister who did her phd
on the top
of the militarization class so even
scientists didn't know where their money
was
so they were seduced right
departments are supposed to be free
because when you're in a university
you're supposed to be not dependent
necessarily on
on racing and there were independent
people like einstein after all he was
working at a hospital when he comes with
his major findings he was free
those guys were free or they came from
rich families but they didn't need the
money the more you needed big technology
the more you needed money more you
needed money the more you had to go to
washington
and or the corporate world
and it's really interesting i was i
invited a bunch of physicists to dinner
about three months ago
and they were all senior physicists big
names from the lord's lab
and
you know physicists can be boring too
so at one point in the conversation i
said what do you think physics should be
like in 10 years
and one guy said
10 years
well he was in the late 70s
he said
bigger machines
and somebody else another physicist said
and more people to run the big machines
and then the wife looked at the senior
guy and she said sounds like a factory
to me
and she was right on
now
the whole business of
egalitarian
and an egalitarian approach that i i
use with these guys when i talk to them
infuriates them but in a way it reveals
it
so when i talk about militaries they all
these things that i've talked
about i've never been screamed at except
by a physical scientist publicly
and the classic one was
when i was giving a talk at stanford
it was being
videoed to
sent to
lawrence berkeley where my husband was
livermore los alamos
and of course the stanford
and after i finished this guy went
berserk and he said you're awful you're
awful you you didn't even show us any
tables there was no qualification you
talked to us like you talked to the next
door neighbor
i said you are the next door
there's a hubris
he thinks of himself as an elite if he's
an elite i should have talked in his
language
not my language
quantified we need less numbers more
pros
so there's a there's a there's a
hierarchy that comes from militarization
and all the labs were started
by the military on a military model
and not all scientists are the same
that's why i got all those letters they
worry too
but they were happy that someone on the
outside what's saying this
let's turn it off
it's in the front the first one
so
it shows kind of the frustration of
being treated like anybody else
and when i
i dedicated one of my books to the
american taxpayer it was paid for
science american taxpayers have been
very generous because i asked the
scientists
i said you know i say things like you've
had millions of dollars i have to hand
it to you because i saw some solarize
partly silverado's building here
millions of dollars to the laura's
birthday lab not one solarize
not one solarized
even at the lab
so i said so where does your money come
from congress no it comes from the
american taxpayer so i dedicated my book
to the generous american taxpayer
or the citizens of young of the future
who have no choice because it's being
made for them
these are areas i tell you
i like to study i mean i like the work
that's being done now in anthropology on
coal and oil and so forth but just keep
on going up
and see what it's about you're studying
cold you're going to hit the companies
look what's happening in west virginia
look what's happening with duke energy
right and come take in the whole picture
don't just look at the coal and the
workers and the downtrodden take it all
away study up down sideways
so
thank you
personally yeah
yeah
so thanks for this great talk
i just wanted to know your you know your
perspective on how these great insights
and further you know this information on
elite anthropology can be
um
you know can be used to
further used to uh influence these
institutions and how can we apply this
you know
information that
and this insights that we're getting
just go public
see what was interesting somebody did a
biography of a star you know kind of a
history of the clines project this
national academy of sciences
and he wanted to interview me
i said why do you want to interview me
he said because you changed the subject
i said i was just one person it was a
pile like this of material right
and when it came to my
uh energy in a democratic society they
did not want to publish it they kept
saying more appropriately and then
finally the way i got it published was
to say either you're ignorant
or you're dishonest take your choice i'm
going to publish this and if you don't
publish it i'll go to the press so i had
to basically threaten i was at the
wilson center at the time in washington
i mean there comes a time when you just
have to say look science is about truth
see when i gave a talk in los alamos
what they really were
it was just talk called barriers to
thinking new
why did i call it that because that's
what they care about
they care about novelty new ideas
creativity right
there is to thinking new what you see
science has various that they do look at
the nobel laureate says that is you
can't say that today so
you have inside help
and if you say it they can quote you
i mean i was just one person
it was very frustrating
it was the hardest field work i ever did
but it's probably the most
important
not as much fun as being with his
architect under music
but it was like i would come in the
house from those meetings and i hit head
for the shower
i felt dirty
how can you talk about two percent of
the population
lose two percent of the population you
have no skin in the game that's why you
can save it
you're not going to be responsible i'm
going to be held responsible
so in terms of you don't have to apply
anthropology you have to go public in
some way
i mean look at deb
david graber's dad
he probably for the year he published
that most famous anthropologist in the
world
not the anthropologist but to everybody
else
why he hit him
everybody's worried about that countries
are worried individuals are worried
right he writes about 5 000 years of
debt or whatever the title was
and so you have to sort of listen to the
public
and see what you know what what are they
ready to have that you have to be
you know whatever now sometimes you just
do it
del hines was asked to do reinventing
anthropology in the 60s
and he asked me to write a paper
i am not an iss i keep saying that
because people always say are you a
marxist or you're a woman i'm not a nist
i'm not a kodian i'm not a ramsey i use
cocoa i use ground sheet depending on
the question but i'm not an ist right so
i wrote it as some kind of total
innocence
i didn't even have i didn't even know
the double entendre of the
anthropologist
because there had been a book called up
the organization
so i sort of copied that
but when people sort of laughed about
the title
it had a huge impact
i was just i was an assistant professor
i had no idea people in my department
didn't even read it for 10 years after
so they were so offended
and now they're called you know that's
swimming upstream and they have various
ways of talking about it so but
anthropologists didn't study power
how can you study coal
or oil or anything without studying
susannah sawyer she happens to be the
daughter of a
of the ceo
so to her it wasn't a big issue and many
of these scientists that wrote me
were all from rich families
so they weren't so scared i'm going to
lose my jaws and so dauntman wasn't
scared because he was also a medical
doctor and he had tenure at berkeley
but that is not free science
so my question when is science
scientific
i'm not saying i'm against science
i'm saying i'm for good science
and then up the anthropologist i did the
same thing i said for our work to be
scientific
we can't just draw the line around the
colonized we have to include the
colonizers for example
you can't just understand the ghetto
without understanding the bank's red
line
so you just push the question up
people are really grateful i mean these
guys are grateful are they always
grateful no
i say to my students but you can't want
to be loved and do this kind of work
okay how many people feel good about
being said you're awful you're awful
my husband's staying in the lab laughing
his head office
i thought it was funny the guy lost the
temper
and only the physicists lose their
temper
because they think they're special and
so on
so but
it when it was published in the
industrial physics you should read the
comments that those guys were in those
are mainly engineers
and it was a geology professor that
suggested they republish barriers to
think he knew about energy he said it's
as good now as it was 40 years ago so
they published
a version of it
and then the guys the engineers started
writing
we don't need some pinko berkeley
professor you know you should it was
funny but i had the answer
and i said i have to explain
anthropology and the long deray
perspective
right to them so you don't answer by
getting defensive you answer like you
know it's a question from uh answer
three class
someone asked a racist question answer
three you don't say you dumbbell you
know you say you explain it to
you have to know how to talk
and you have to talk english
i think the worst thing has happened in
our field is jargon
we used to be the best
we used to be the best writers
when i got my phd anthropology was peak
people could understand up they read
mirror for man by clock holder was a
bestseller
and he has a chapter and asked paul just
looks at the united states and as paul
just looks at the world he had scope
he said anthropology had possibility
then we went into this whole period
damning anthropology naval gazing
you know
we didn't study the colonizers calling
or wrong anthropologies all that but
whatever
it's like any other field not some good
things it's like physics not some
problems and so on but you don't just
make a living damn in the field you're
in
and thinking it's all about social
philosophy and thinking you've got
theory
that was what's interesting they started
damning ethnography
just description we watched theory siri
so i thought you know i didn't get it so
i looked up the word theory in the
dictionary somehow it didn't click
theory either describes or explains
according to webster
right
and philosophy is conceptual
so they were going to the european
philosophers for theory but they were
getting conceptual material
and then they became a fukodian or
whatever whatever they became you know
into anthropology and then the words
words aren't sort of
and it's like commerce
i'm telling you there's some there's
some linguists at the university of
chicago's
chicago
he insists that what he says is so
important you should work hard to
understand what he says who's that time
you know
i mean i'll give you the first lesson i
learned about germany
tackle parsons you know who he is
all right sociologists
although parcels gave the first talk i
went to at harvard
i talked for an hour and did not
understand what the subject was
right
and i thought
i'm dumb
i can't even understand what the subject
matter
then um
what's the name a sociologist um
how can i forget seriously right now no
you think he's a colombian no the
sociologist at harvard who
never got a phd but he was professing
sociology how can i forget his name the
human group
anyways he got up and he said chocolate
are you saying
that the more people get to know each
other the more they like each other
talcott said yes and homers with
homeless home and sat down and i thought
that was the last time anybody was going
to pull the will over my eyes
can you believe
it's the same with a lot that's
happening in our field
we used to be the books that everybody
bought
malinowski wrote for the scientists the
public matter of science and religion he
was conscious of that
you write books people buy it
so
we've in a way we've lost our way
at a time when we're desperately needed
the generalist anthropology is
desperately needed
we have a role to play
can i tell them a joke
it's about falco person's joke
they're a bunch of psychiatrists and
they had a meeting in california
and they sort of got the thing mixed up
they're supposed to go to a psychiatric
hospital
california modern circuit council
and then they were going to go to the
center for advanced study
but they got it mixed up so they went to
the center thinking it was a
psychiatrist
and this pudgy guy was walking across
the lawn
and so
one of the psychiatrists
and who are you
he said i'm talking parsons and the guy
says to the other psychiatrists dig that
he thinks he's tale kick parts
other questions
very critical of scientists and probably
rightly so but i'm just wondering if you
can give us a bit more texture to the
different kinds of scientists from
ethnographic subjects
and i'm wondering particularly
if you have found people who actually
want to take out the kind of political
approach that you're promoting and
through the same resistance within the
ranks and how um
those kinds of
encounters
hugh gustafson come to mind
all the people who wrote me letters for
science yeah they were nobel laureates
they were heads in the laboratory there
were no students in rome they're all big
guys
so they're worried about creativity
they're worrying about ethics they're
worried about thinking science is
everything
so
that's why i say within the science
community there's a huge diversity but
then there's the power structure
the people in this case the military
and so i guess the question is that what
kind of um you know pragmatically
speaking what kind of support or um you
know kind of solidarity can be built
with people who are within those ranks
who are trying to engineer
change because i know from personal
experience that they're very much there
so then the question is you know what
what could an anthropologist do then
um
or how have you pursued those
kinds of relationships further
you might look take a look at naked
science a chapter of the three-quarter
constellation
magic science and religion
and if you look at hugh gusterson's look
in a way
i feel that i've helped
the younger scientists want to do this
kind of work like he was studying uh
nevermind
and he didn't have cover so he had to go
in he couldn't get
access so he had to do it with the bars
and
the churches and so forth
they're both stand for students but
nobody at stanford is doing this kind of
work so i
they used to be sent they used to send
them to me
and so i would i would call that
mentoring mentoring the younger faculty
and and of course
when i teach a course called this course
science and power
i get a lot of this small course but
interesting people mainly medical
doctors
who want to know about science and
knowledge they're interested in
pharmaceuticals and they're interested
in
improving the delivery of science there
is just too much technology in medicine
and things like that
but
little by little
it's not a you
know if you had said to me
50 years ago you're going to be studying
energy maybe involved with scientists
it's serendipitous
but my rock
my rock was the anthropology of law
so in fact in effect i guess i'm saying
that if you have a rock
something that you make your reputation
on your ethnographic you know your first
ethnographic work and so on that gives
you freedom
to do all kinds of things so i go into
the gender field and
follow your curiosity and do the things
that you want i mean this book that i
just published
called culture and dignity
you have to educate the people that are
reading it
reviewing it
i mean like they said things like why
dignity i had a title for my book like
uh
political historical and blah blah blah
in the middle east
who wants to read that
really culture and daniel why culture
and why dignity everybody's talking
about dignity
they didn't know it the marketing people
didn't know it either the marketing
people are the worst because you can get
your book published in the marketing
people say you know you should do this
but they kept sending me camels and
pictures for the cover you know the
whole notion of what the middle east was
very clueless
so but you have to educate them
at every step of the way
you have to educate the bureaucracy in
your universities too
it's a great time to be an
anthropologist
there's never been in my time a better
time to be an astrologer
you've got nothing to lose
and lots of issues very important
and if you don't have any jobs you can
do whatever you want right on
whatever you can
don't just sit and despair
it's really you know it's a wonderful
time for us followers there's a there's
a
huge gap
we're more ethnocentric in this country
now than when i was in graduate school
american exceptionalism
ignorance our president doesn't even
know the relationship between crimea and
russia
ignorance at the top
hillary clinton everywhere she goes you
know she's you didn't treat your women
that way
she doesn't know how women are treated
in the united states
we've got a bunch of congressmen they're
telling women how to how to use their
bodies
it's so insulting 2014.
and there's a feminist movement
supposedly
a bunch of congressmen at the local
level the state level and the federal
level are telling women what to do in
their bodies
and when my mom tried to explain
abortion issue to my mother
at 95 she sat up in her chair and she
said not their business
when did it become the business of the
state you see how one thing leads to
another
in the latter part of the 19th century
wasn't their business
homosexuality wasn't the business of the
state either
until recently
now how does that happen so
the ingredient you need
is indignation and curiosity and then
the talents that you're given in
graduate school the training you're
training
great time to be nas police
yeah
from some to some degree i do agree that
the right time to be colleges
ever since i took your classes at
berkeley it seems like questions of like
area study and like geographic
like area sites and sort of like
fashion the way that you
are sort of like inculcated into
becoming a professional you need to be
associated with some place over there as
opposed to like
um you know just studying up so i guess
my question to you is like
um in regards to historical memory
because you have an institutional memory
because you've been at burping for so
long what are sort of like
the barriers to thinking up
in terms of like the discipline of
anthropology well if you have a rock
something that's acceptable in the field
like studying the anthropology of law
then you can do it in your wrong
basically
so i kept on and i and all my public
pieces i never showed to anybody
until i came up for full professorship
and and alan dundee's came into my
office and i want it all give me all of
it but you know you guys think there's
no money i want to do my first sales
work on twelve hundred dollars in the
mexican government
the american government was putting all
this money into africa at that time
but i wanted to go to mexico so i went
to mexico i could have said oh i'll go
to africa that's for the money i want to
go to mexico i want to go to ohaka there
was a blank on the map i wanted to see
what was there
so you have to sort of be
self-driven in a way
and
i got a letter from a student
a day before i came and she said
i'm in despair
i've been looking for a job for two
years now she just got her phd in 2013.
i said it's too early to be in debate
start writing do something
so
i think that
anthropologists had more money today
than we ever had
and more posts there were no post docs
when i was coming
but there was
passion
it wasn't a career it was passion and
part of it i learned from the veterans
because when i was in graduate school
is when the veterans all came back to
graduate school and they had all been in
the philippines or like cal confluence
now came back to study anthropology and
to them they were passionate
it's not a career
i love the field why because it's wide
open
you can follow your curiosity
wherever
who would have said i'd be an energy who
would have said i'd be writing about
gender you know i get mad at what idiocy
i read in the feminist literature so it
makes me write up write a piece
and the area courses they gave me so
much trouble with this book on on
the subtitle the dialogues between the
middle east and the west the area people
didn't know what to do with it how are
you going to use that in anthropology of
the middle east
and so i wrote a piece on area studies
they're military
it's a military term and i published it
in the anthropology newsletter it didn't
have to be too long and they take things
right you can write things forward
and it got a lot of hits
a lot of response because a lot of
people were thinking that they weren't
writing about it
you're lucky
you're lucky to be in a department to
support us and so on and you're very
lucky
hold up fox and raise hell
hi i have two questions one of them is
regarding energy policy and citizen
participation how
how do you think what what do you think
would be appropriate to get more
citizens to participate in energy policy
between those two and then my second
question would be
um
what do you think about the women in
basically visits that if there were
women at all in the committee
we used to think that there are more
women things will be different
you know
we've gone from thinking that women have
destroyed women's culture we've merged
women's culture in men's health
in the united states so we used to talk
about women making peace
but what happens when they're now
fighting to be in the war on the front
are you kidding
they're getting raped and the feminists
are not doing anything about it
they should be raising you
where are they asleep they think they're
born the woman's one
so one of the things we've learned
is
if you're black it doesn't mean you
can't be corrupt and dumb
just like the white men
it's character
it's not gender or race or color
but we keep thinking like we only had a
black president
everybody voted i should do a bunch of
races if you vote for obama because he's
black you're racist
period
if you vote for hillary clinton because
she's a woman you're a sexist i don't
care whether you're women or man
who cares
at this point this is critical in our in
our society this is a really critical
time for democracy
we're barely a democracy
i just talked to a couple of young
people one of whom i knew when they were
kids
one left for new zealand because for
australia because she thinks this is a
police state
and the other one is going into
philanthropy
because she wants to just do good you
know she wants to improve on the
question of how to get people interested
in
the people you should get are the
faculty
the universities
civic involvement at the university
level we're asleep
and
i when i gave my talk on energy in my
hometown in winston
it was amazing all these people showed
up they were solarizing their houses
they were doing all these things we are
a bunch of elitists and we should get
off of that i got a call from a woman
who says she's related to me some
distant relative etc she said i'm now in
public health and i need your advice i'm
going to go help the booga booga do such
and such
what would you have to advise me i hope
you could advise first you're not going
to help them at all
able to go and learn from them
the idea that i'm going to go help
humanitarian impulse is very sick
it's not a good thing if it's mutual
it'll work it's not mutual it's false
and it becomes a pre
becomes an avenue for imperialism
so
you have to have mutual respect
mutual respect
so the guy that said you're awful to me
i didn't recognize him as an elite
that's why he was so mad at me
he's just like anybody else
he said you talk to me like i was the
next door neighbor
yes
you are the next one
and that's the way we should be talking
about mutual respect
you know something i don't know i know
something you don't know
honestly i don't know what other
direction to go in these issues
the solar movement is bottom up
it's a lot and a lot of kids are in this
in california and so on and they're
doing experiments and you know in my
energy reader the energy reader we've
seen it or not but i have a bunch of
action pieces
they're doing
the native americans are doing it
they're not just complaining
they're out there doing solar doing all
the alternative conservation efficiency
itself
and the just plain folks are doing it
so we can learn from them and we can say
oh hey maybe you should do it this way
the thing that boggles your mind is i
mean just think of this we can go to the
moon
but we can't find out what happened to
the malaysian plane
i just can't believe that
there's a technology to go to the moon
we can't solve the simple problems we
have how can that be i went around
saying how can that be
how could it be
we can talk about solar millions of
dollars tax tax money
at the lab mostly
thank you yes
you just ask
how can that be
and i think what's happened is that the
deliberative process in society has
really broken down it's not working
and if we're going to be able to solve
these problems we're going to have to
restore
and improve that deliberative process
and you know the question
also was how do you do that
you encourage debate
i don't mean screening i mean debate
you should be you should say i don't
agree with you for the following reasons
and i say well how much evidence do you
get i'm telling you i thought i'll argue
with that
debate
you can't there's no debate today
i mean that's what governor brown was
talking about and called me up one day
said what is can't talk to anybody
everything is pc
that's a controlling process peace you
have to be nice the niceness of it
has to be nice
so deliberative now some people i mean
some people i know in washington are
having debates on taboos things that you
can't talk about
and they have them regularly but these
they should be happening in everything
yeah right
what happened to what happened to you i
mean how many articles have been written
about what's happened to the
progressives in our country
okay people will say
it's a weak democracy it's known
democracy or we're losing democracy
secrecy is all the rest
i was telling chris and some others the
most interesting thing about interesting
thing about snowden is they never went
to college
and stayed home never went to college
what does that say about what we're
getting at education in college
are we being taught to critically think
i would say no
yeah
so thank you all for coming um we're out
of time now um chris would you say they
were refreshments or is that
or after or we just have a little bit of
seasoning okay so we have tea and coffee
if those would like to linger and have
conversation um but thank you all for
coming and thank you especially uh
professor nader
you